Godzilla king of monsters yeah this is
the number one movie in America crazy in
the world
some people are your seems I know that
you a lot of your scenes are in sort of
like an observation room we're keeping
an eye on what Godzilla's up to yeah
yeah I was like all big crazy action
movie I'm gonna be I'm gonna be like in
there like chatting and all that kind of
stuff no I'm on like the bridge of a
ship just going like we got him on radar
is so funny I got no one sells a movie
like you yeah we I get to sit on my
cloud you know it's a big-budget movie
and I see this huge hydraulic thing and
like the sets on top of them like oh man
we're gonna be like moving around like
it's a university yeah and they're like
now that actually that's not working
we're just gonna do it the old-school
way
and that meant for weeks on end being in
a chair and like the assistant director
being like and look it over there and
boom and then the camera shake and we go
like this
wait this is like an 800 billion dollar
movie yeah baby
honey would shake the camera and you
guys would go like that vintage Star
Trek stuff what and it is we could do
this right here and I frankly suggest
that if if you would be so kind as to be
the assistant director and sort of call
out what's happening like Godzilla's
inviting a door or whatever and then as
soon as a boom will shake and that's
okay and you know at one point maybe
like right down the barrel be like be
like my god who says that that's you
right okay I'll say well you say you
kick us off but like we got them on
radar okay I don't need a line reading
let me do it my way okay
Jesus we got him on radar
whose sarcastic about Godzilla we got
him on radar some king of the monsters
he is alright alright let's get started
with the scene alright and Andy will
anyway I guess do it about boom one okay
yeah yeah hey we got him on radar boo
[Applause]
Hey
how many people at home just puked I was
looking at that I'm like I'm getting
gnashing yeah
I didn't shake cuz I was just the
assistant yeah I love in all that
footage we're shaking and Andy's just
sitting there I'm the assistant director
I don't get about that yeah alright we
have a clip from the real gods oh it's
probably 11 percent better than what we
just show yeah let's take a look
[Music]
with the light show it's an intimidation
display top you were looking at a blue
light
I mean where's your you had you had to
look at a blue light and act like you
were seeing you just like the face of
God that's you acting yeah it is real
acting yeah you're right
for someone who's ruined it yeah it is a
wild ride you got to go see it you got
to go see a scenery big theater it's
crazy it's fun it's hot it's from its
tip to taint action all right